PROFESSOR: So we're
building this story.
We had the photoelectric effect.
But at this moment,
Einstein, in the same year
that he was talking
about general relativity,
he came back to the photon.
And there there's actually a
quote of Einstein's saying,
his greatest
discoveries, for sure,
were special relativity
and general relativity.
The photo-- he got
the Nobel Prize
for the photoelectric effect,
and he certainly helped
invent the quantum theory
and many important things
in this subject, but in
retrospect, his greatest
successes were that.
But he may have not quite
seen it exactly that way.
He wrote, that some
stage of his whole life
had been a difficult struggle
against the quantum, pulsed
by some small happy interludes
of some other discoveries.
But the quantum theory
certainly made him very--
well, he was very suspicious
about the truth, the deep truth
of the quantum theory.
So 1916, he is busy
with general relativity,
but then he's more ready
to admit that the photon is
a particle, because he adds
that the photon now has momentum
as well.
So it's a-- these photons that
were not called photons yet
are quanta for energy.
But now he adds it's
also for momentum.
So this already
characterizes particles.
You see, there is the
relativistic relation, well
known by then, that e squared
minus p squared c squared
is equal to m squared
c to the fourth.
You might say, well, this
is a little surprising.
And If you don't remember
too much special relativity,
this may not quite be
your favorite formula.
Your favorite formulas might
be that the energy is mc
squared divided by 1 minus
v squared over c squared.
And that the momentum
is the ordinary momentum
again multiplied by this
denominator like this.
But these two equations,
with a little bit of algebra,
yield this equation,
which summarizes something
about a particle,
that basically if you
know the energy and the
momentum of a particle,
you know its mass.
And it comes out from this.
This is the relativistic
version of similar equations
in which you have energy one
half mv squared, momentum, mv,
and then energy equal p squared
over 2m, a very important
relation that you can check.
For out of these
two comes this one.
And this is nonrelativistic.
So for photons, we will
have particles of zero mass.
Photons have zero mass, m
of the photon equals zero,
and therefore e is equal
to pc for a photon.
So we can look at what
the photon momentum is,
for example photon momentum.
We can treat it as some
particle and the photon momentum
would be e of the photon
divided by c, or h
Nu of the photon divided by c.
And it's h over lambda
of the photon of gamma.
So this is a very
interesting relation
between the momentum
of the photon
and the wavelength of photons.
So the idea that the
photon is really a particle
is starting to gather
evidence, but people were not
convinced about it until
Compton did his work.
So the same Compton that we
used this length over there,
he works on this problem
and does the following.
So is Compton scattering,
the name of the work.
Compton Scattering.
So what is Compton scattering?
It is x-rays shining
on atoms again,
but this time, these are
very energetic photons,
energetic x-rays.
X-rays can have anything
from a hundred EV
to 100kEV, 100,000
electron volts.
And what are the energies,
of binding energies
of electrons in atoms?
10 EV, 13 EV for
hydrogen. So you're
talking about
100,000 EV coming in,
so it's easily going to shake
electrons and release them
very easily.
So you're going to have almost--
even though you're
shining on electrons
that are bound to
atoms, it's almost
like shining light on free
electrons if it's x-rays.
So a few things happening.
So this is photons
scattering on electrons.
Scattering on electrons
that are virtually free.
And the first thing
that happens is
that there is a
violation of what
was called the classical
Thomson scattering, that you
may have started in 802.
So the reason Compton
scattering did
the job and physicists
finally admitted
the photon was a
particle is that it made
it look like particle collision
of a photon with an electron,
it could calculate
and measure and treat
the photon as a particle, just
like another particle like
the electron, and out
came the right result.
So the classical
Thomson scattering
was a photon as a wave.
And what does that do?
Well, you have a free
electron, and here comes
an electromagnetic
wave, E and B.
And if it's low frequency
wave, low energy electron,
this electric--
the magnetic field
does very little, because this
election doesn't move too fast
and the velocity is being
small, the Lorentz force
is very small.
But the electric field
shakes the electron.
And as the electron is being
shaken, it's accelerating,
and therefore it
radiates itself.
And it radiates in a pattern,
so you get photons out.
And the pattern
is the following.
I'll write the formula
with this cross-section.
We'll maybe not explain
too much about what
this cross-section
means, it could
be a nice thing for recitation.
This is the formula for
the Thomson cross-section
as a function of the
angle between the incident
direction of the photon and
the photon that emerges.
So you detect photons out and
this is the cross-section.
What does it mean,
cross-section?
Well this has units.
I will say, very
briefly, units of area.
Area per solid angle, but
solid angle has no units.
So if you imagine a
little solid angle here
and you multiply by
this cross-section,
it gives you some
area that represents
the solid angle you're
looking at to see
how many photons you get.
And the solid angle that
you have multiplied here
to give you an area,
the area should
be thought of as the area that
captures from the incoming beam
the energy that is being
sent into this solid angle.
So it represents an area, and
an area represents an energy,
because if you have a beam
coming in from a magnetic wave
through a little area,
some energy goes in.
So that area that
you get is that area
that extracts from
the incident beam
the energy that you need to go
in this solid angle direction.
So basically, this is a plot
of intensity of the radiation
as a function of angle.
But the most important
thing, not only-- this
is not quite accurate when
the photon is of high energy.
The thing that is
pretty wrong about this
is that the outgoing photon
or wave has the same frequency
as the original wave.
So that's a property
of this scattering.
The electron is being
moved at the frequency
of the electric
field, and therefore
the frequency of the
radiation is the same.
And this is all classical.
But out comes, when
you have a high energy,
this thing is not accurate, and
you have a different result.
So what did Compton find?
Well, the first thing is
a couple of observations.
.
Treat the photon as a particle.
OK, so it has some
energy and some momentum.
The electron has some
energy and momentum.
You should analyze the collision
using energy and momentum
conservation.
So before the collision,
you have an incoming photon
that has some energy
and some momentum,
and you have an
electron, maybe here.
And then after a
while, the electron
flies away in some
direction, E minus.
And the photon also, a photon
prime of different frequency
flies away.
It's like a collision.
You can do this calculation
and maybe it could even
be done in recitation.
It's a relativistic calculation.
You were asked in first homework
to show that the photon can not
be absorbed by the
electron, and that
uses the relativistic
relations if you
want to show you
just can't absorb it.
It's not consistent with energy
and momentum conservation.
So it's something you
can try to figure out.
The other thing that
should become obvious
is that the photon is
going to lose some energy,
because as it hits the electron,
it gives the electron a kick.
The electron now
has kinetic energy.
Think of this in the lab.
The electron was static,
the photon was coming.
After a while, the
electron has moved,
it's moving now
with some velocity.
The photon must have
lost some energy.
So photon loses energy.
And therefore, the final
lambda must be bigger
than the initial lambda.
Remember the shorter the
wavelength, the more energetic
the photon is.
So what is the difference?
That's the result
of a calculation.
It's a nice calculation,
all of you should do it.
It's probably in some
book, in many books.
And it's a nice exercise
also for recitation.
Lambda final minus
lambda initial.
Or I'll write it differently.
Lambda final is equal to
lambda initial plus something
that depends on the angle
theta, in fact, has a one
minus cosine theta dependence.
But here has to be something
with units of length
And the only party you
have here is the electron.
And this electron
has some length,
which is the quantum
wavelength, which
is very natural for a Compton
scattering problem, of course.
And it's here, h over mec.
So the l Compton
of the electron.
And that's the correct formula
for the loss of energy,
or change in frequency.
So the most you can get is if
you don't interact when theta
is equal to zero, the
photon keeps going,
doesn't even kick the electron.
And then you get zero,
the initial lambda
is equal to the final lambda.
But this can be as large as two,
for totally backwords photon
emitted.
So theta equals pi, cosine
pi is minus 1, you get 2.
At 90 degrees, you
get the Compton shift.
So it's a very nice
thing, you even
know already what's
happening here.
So let's describe the experiment
itself, of how it was done.
So he used, Compton,
the experiment
have a source of
molybdenum x-rays
that have lambda equals
0.0709 nanometers.
So smaller than nanometers,
it's 70 picometers.
And that corresponds
to e photon--
that's pretty small, so
it must be high energy--
and it's 17.49 kEV.
That's very big energy.
And there was a
carbon foil here.
And you send the photons
in this direction.
And they were observed
at several degrees,
but in particular,
I'll show you a plot
of how it looked for theta
equal 90 degrees, so detector.
So source comes in, carbon is
there, and what do you get?
You get the following plot.
Intensity-- so you plot the
intensity of the photons
that you detect, as a
function of the wavelength
of the photons that you
get, because there's
supposed to be a wavelength,
a shift of wavelength.
So it's actually
quite revealing,
because you get
something like this.
A bump and a bigger bump here.
Something like that.
Pretty surprising, I think,
to first approximation.
And here is about--
the first bump happens to
have about the same wavelength
as the incoming
radiation, 0.0709.
I should write it a
little more to the left.
0.0709 nanometers over here.
And then there is
another peak at lambda f,
about 0.0731 nanometers.
And the question is, what
is the interpretation?
Why are there two peaks
and what's going on?
Anybody has any idea?
Let me ask a simpler question.
Which is the lambda
that corresponds
to the prediction of the
fact that the wavelength must
change, the smaller
one or the bigger one?
The bigger one.
You certainly should loose
energy, so the lambda
f, the thing we were expecting
to see, presumably that thing,
because we were expecting
to see that at 90 degrees,
the photons have this thing.
So we seem to observe this one.
And let's look at it in
a little more detail.
You have this 0.0731 nanometers
and you have the original light
was at 0.0709 nanometers.
So the difference is
0.0022 nanometers,
which is 10 to the minus 9, but
it's exactly, or pretty close,
to this thing,
because a picometer is
10 to the minus 3 nanometers.
So this is 0.0024 nanometers.
So this is pretty nice.
Look, at 90 degrees,
cosine theta is zero.
So the difference between
initial and final wavelengths
should be equal to
the Compton wavelength
with about 0.0024 nanometers.
And that's about
it pretty close.
So this peak is all right.
Should've been there.
The other peak, why is it there?